and the Oscar goes
to hair love Matthew a chry and Karen
River there were so many filmmakers that
worked so hard on this and it was a
labor of love and it was because we have
a firm belief that representation
matters
deeply especially especially in cartoons
because in cartoons that's when we first
see our movies and it's how I we shape
our lives and think about how we see the
world we we have a big team know we have
to thank but time is running short so I
just want to say that hair love was done
because we wanted to see more
representation in animation we wanted to
normalize black hair there's a very
important issue that's out there it's
the crown act and if we can help to get
this passing off 50 states it will help
stories like DeAndre Arnolds who's our
special guest tonight sto to
happen this award is dedicated to Kobe
Bryant may we all have a second act as
great as his was thank you